Technology and jobs has been in the news recently.
You may have noticed manufacturing jobs for instance,
there's been a huge decline in manufacturing as a share of employment,
uh,
technology in my view.
And I think the view of most economists is the main factor for that.
So this chart shows the decline in cotton textile manufacturing from 1940,
uh,
about over 70% of that is due to technology since 2000.
It's true trade has played a much more dominant role,
uh,
as terrorists,
terrorists and,
and the restraints on trade have been relaxed.
Uh,
but technology is the big story.
We also have new technologies coming on that are going to accelerate this
process.
Machine learning,
artificial intelligence technologies.
One study a few years ago came out and said that 44 47% of the total us
employment is potentially automateable over perhaps the next decade or two.
My book goes back and looks at Tech Tech,
the technology of the past.
Um,
and some people are very dismissive about anything having to do with history and
technology.
Uh,
I think I'll paraphrase canes,
which says that people who ignore history,
uh,
are slaves to a defunct economist.
Um,
the aim of,
of history here is not to dismiss the current challenges is not to say,
oh,
it all worked out in the past.
It's going to work out just fine.
Don't you worry.
No,
it's to understand them.
We can.
And the only way we can understand,
uh,
the,
the nature of how technology impacts societies to see what it's done so far.
Not that it's going to necessarily be the same,
but that's how we know what questions to ask.
Okay.
I'm going to in fact argue that the idea of the end of work in the near future,
the next 10 or 20 years isn't really the,
the main challenge.
The main challenge is generating the skills to work with a new technology.
I know on a social scale.
So it's,
it's scarce skills,
not scarce jobs.
And this is important,
uh,
because we have to understand what the real problem is that we're going to
understand what kind of policies you want to put in place to fix it.
If we,
we address the wrong problem.
If for instance,
we raise tariffs because we think it's trade that has destroyed most of the
jobs.
Uh,
we're not,
we may make things worse and we're not going to solve the real problem.
And I think the same thing is true with the end of work arguments.
So let me start with,
with a bit of history.
Um,
first I'm going to make a point from history that automation in fact can create
jobs and often does,
uh,
automation is nothing new.
So going back to those,
the textile industry,
this is a picture of the we've room of a textile mill and fall river,
fall river,
Massachusetts from about 1910 over a hundred years ago.
And if you look closely,
you'll see that there are very many machines and very few workers already.
Over a hundred years ago,
we had a very high level of automation and this was nothing new.
I,
the best mills at that time would have 24 looms per weaver.
Um,
so,
and in fact,
if you look at,
at the course of automation over the 19th century,
uh,
compare,
what,
uh,
somebody could do what a weaver could do in the B at the beginning of the
century on a handloom,
excuse me,
98% of the,
uh,
of the work was automated by,
by 1910.
Very few,
only some of the task,
very few of the tests we remained for workers to do
that.
In fact,
that didn't create massive unemployment.
It didn't create 90 eliminate 98% of the jobs.
In fact,
if I show you the full chart,
uh,
of the,
of the initial charge,
you'll see that
throughout the 19th century job's jobs rose rapidly in the cotton textile
industry.
All the while this,
this heavy automation was going on.
All the while machines were taking over work from humans,
but nevertheless,
employment increased.
So there's a real,
there's a real question here.
Why is it that sometimes,
uh,
tech not automation can increase jobs and other times it eliminates them.
Um,
I can clearly go both ways and,
and the answer is,
uh,
it has to do with consumer demand.
So for first,
first ignore the chart at the beginning of the 19th century that a typical
person might have one set of clothes.
They had very little cloth,
otherwise Clark was extremely expensive.
Uh,
much of it was made at home in the household.
It was extremely tedious to do.
It took a lot of time.
Uh,
so people had very little of it.
When automation came in and started reducing the amount of labor required to
produce a yard of cloth,
it don't meant that the price went down because there's competition and when the
price went down,
people responded by buying quite a bit more cloth because now they could get a
second pair of clothes.
And as,
as it became progressively cheaper,
they could start using cloth and other things.
They could put up draperies and,
and upholster furniture.
Um,
but finally you get to the 20th century,
the middle of the 20th century and cloth is cheap and a further price reduction
just isn't going to provoke a lot of people to go out.
And buy a whole lot more cloth.
You know,
you have a very strong response to price changes in the early years when
productivity is very low.
But when demand is largely saturated,
you have a very small response.
And that's the difference because what,
so what happens is in the early years,
demand increases.
A lot of people buy a lot more cloth.
They buy so much more that even though less labor is needed to produce a yard of
cloth,
there are that many more yards of cloth produced that the,
that the workforce goes up.
But since 1920 or 1940,
uh,
the reverse is true that when you drop the price of a cloth by making it more
efficient to produce people buy a little bit more,
but not enough to offset the job losses.
And that's why you see this,
this inverted u pattern.
And that's why automation doesn't always,
uh,
decrease employment.
It can increase it.
What about today?
We're seeing lots of new technologies coming on.
Are they increasing?
Are they decreasing work?
Well,
we can look at some examples.
So we had barcode scanners come into grocery stores and retail outlets in the
1980s and actually there were more cashiers employed even though it tucked cut
down on their labor.
We have ecommerce coming in so far it's meant more salespeople,
uh,
electronic discovery of legal documents.
Uh,
computers are doing a great job at,
at sifting through massive amounts of legal documents,
but in fact what's happened is demand is increased so that now there are that
many more legal documents that are going undergoing discovery and we're seeing
more paralegals being employed.
Uh,
my,
one of my favorite examples is the ATM and the bank teller.
Uh,
we had from 1995 to 2005,
just a huge increase in the number of ATM is deployed by US banks.
But in fact,
the number of bank tellers went up and went up actually faster than the labor
force in general.
What happened?
Well,
they only needed 13 tellers operator branch instead of 21 and made it cheaper to
operate a branch.
And so what is it the banks do?
They opened up a lot more branches.
They increased demand and so many more branches that in fact the number of
tellers went up.
Uh,
it's not uniformly true that every bit of come new computer technology,
information technology increases jobs.
If you look across sectors,
manufacturing,
uh,
is associated with a decrease in,
in jobs with information from an associated with information technology.
Um,
that goes along with what we've seen.
Early manufacturing has undergone 200 years of progressive automation and so
demand is relatively saturated,
but in lots of other areas we're seeing demands that haven't been touched.
We're,
we're seeing,
uh,
information technology being used for all sorts of new applications and things
that haven't been done before.
Things that haven't been automated before.
And so we were seeing a typically a more positive response.
So that in fact that overall the story is that information technology is in
industries or an occupations is associated with the job growth,
not job declines.
Saturated demand.
Yes.
It's not all a positive story though.
So there are winners and losers.
Okay.
Uh,
these are typesetters from the New York Times in 1940.
So,
uh,
publications back then were these,
these people sat there on these machines,
which,
which spit out slugs have led with the,
with the inverse of the,
uh,
the type words of have a line of type those that they are called Lionel type
machines.
Um,
and those little slug,
those metal slugs were assembled and,
and the,
and that formed the basis for printing pages of a newspaper or a book.
Uh,
we saw computers come along and desktop publishing,
electronic publishing,
and the number of type setters just plummeted from 80,000 to 20,000 in a decade.
Okay.
But lots of those jobs were essentially taken over by graphic designers or
desktop publishers,
people working at computers.
Now,
uh,
we're doing that same work plus more.
They could assemble the pages and redesign them and tweak them in various ways.
So the,
the computer software made things much more powerful,
much more flexible.
Uh,
it made it much easier to make revisions.
So there was a substitution of one occupation for another,
and what you have is a decline in the number of jobs for type setters,
but an even greater increase in the number of jobs for graphic designers.
So one,
one change offset another,
the net change is still positive,
but they're definitely winners and losers.
And if you happen to be someone who was in a blue collar type setting occupation
and gone through an apprenticeship program,
you have to get a new set of skills if you want to remain employed.
And so that's really where the problem comes in.
We've,
let's go back again to,
to,
to the challenge of skills that came up in the past.
This is Lowell,
Massachusetts on the Merrimack River.
Uh,
the Merrimack river valley was sort of the silicon valley of the 19th century,
early 19th century industrial revolution in the u s uh,
the mills.
They're recruited a young farm,
girls from all over northern New England to come in to live in boarding houses
and work these new new fangled automated machines.
Uh,
one girl who entered this is Lucy Larkin.
I'm a girl who,
she has a girl at 12.
She entered the mills and uh,
1830,
18,
40,
[inaudible],
early 1840s.
Um,
while she was in the mill,
she studied German.
She took classes in botany.
She heard lectures by John Quincy Adams and Ralph Waldo Emerson,
the mill girls put out of a magazine.
There were multiple magazines they put out and she published poetry in,
in one of them and became a known by two John Greenleaf Whittier,
who became a mentor and friend.
She compared in her later life,
she compare working in the mills in those days to going to college.
Uh,
and it was very much designed by the mill owners to be a culturally and
intellectually enriching experience in order to attract the most talented
people.
Um,
we tend to think of factory workers as being unskilled and,
and that's not really right.
Uh,
these people who were skilled but they didn't learn in a classroom,
they learned on the job.
They experience learning by doing.
So there were all these new things required of the new technology that people
needed to know how to build it.
They needed it to know how to install it,
to operate it,
how to maintain it,
how to organize production.
Had a market all along the way for every job involve the war,
a whole new set of things to be learned.
And for a number of reasons,
they couldn't be learned in school.
They had to be learned on the job.
Uh,
this shows what's called a learning curve.
the productivity of a group of weavers,
the number of months they had worked on the job.
And what'd you can see is that when they started working,
they were not very productive and they doubled or tripled or quadrupled their
productivity over the space of a year.
So people became more productive.
That represents a very substantial investment in skills.
And it was learning those skills on the job that was critical.
And that was the reason in order to acquire people who,
who could co who could learn those skills.
Well,
they,
the mills sought to recruit the best and the brightest.
On the other hand,
they learn new skills,
but it took them a long time before they got better wages.
Uh,
for many decades wages were stagnant.
And one of the basic problems was,
you know,
what the essential reason was that uh,
the labor markets didn't reward the new skills?
Well either.
So we,
this is the,
here's the problem of,
of skills and new technology which created such a challenge in the 19th century.
Two things about a major new technology.
One is it's not standardized.
You have different versions of it.
Uh,
those versions change frequently and overall the technology is rapidly changing.
What that means is number one,
schools can keep up.
It's changing too quickly.
It's not standardized.
The people who have it are the labor market who have the skills and have the
knowledge are at a premium.
They're going to earn a lot more doing it,
then they are teaching it.
Second,
labor markets have a difficult time recognizing those skills and rewarding
people for having acquired them.
Uh,
there are different versions of those skills acquired.
So an employer who wants to hire somebody with the right skills has a hard time
figuring out whether they really have the right skills and,
and,
and a result of this,
you have wages that are stagnant for a long period of time.
The average wages stagnant and you have rising inequality.
Some people do prosper.
So current day context,
again in 1976 in real dollar terms,
those type setters made $19 and 30 cents an hour.
In 2014,
that graphic designer made $20 and 7 cents an hour,
just a little bit more over a long period of time and,
and performing a job that is now much more sophisticated and much more skilled
than the typesetter job.
What's going on.
The same problem you had initially type sitters and compositors who learned in
an apprenticeship program.
They were soon replaced by print designers and desktop publisher.
But then along came the Internet and now we needed web designers and then mobile
designers and now we have specialties,
information architects,
user interaction specialists.
The,
the skills of the trade are constantly changing.
Um,
schools are struggling to keep graphic design.
Schools are struggling to keep up a labor.
Markets are having a hard time understanding who has the right skills.
Standards are changing in 2012 flash was required for an awful lot of website
design flashes pretty much obsolete today.
Html five became the,
the reigning standard.
This sort of turnover makes things difficult.
So the,
the average designer has a prince,
a print,
a design background.
The schools don't have difficulty teaching.
Uh,
the,
the latest skills.
In fact,
they may rely on,
on some of the,
the moocs to,
for people to get the skills.
Labor markets have a hard time recognizing those skills.
The top people,
the top designers can teach themselves.
Every new thing is it comes along and they can develop reputations so that the
labor market issues are less significant.
But what you get is the average designer has stagnant pay.
The top designers see,
see rising pay.
And so you see growing inequality.
Um,
so for instance,
if you look,
and this is true across occupations,
uh,
affected by computers.
So com occupations on the,
on the right,
that,
that have a lot of people use computers.
You're seeing a rapidly growing gap between the 90th percentile wage and the
50th percentile wage.
Other occupations,
there's not much change.
There is growing inequality related to the use of computers.
And it's this,
this gap between the median worker who can't acquire the skills or has it,
has difficulty acquiring the skills are getting recognized for the skills and
the top people who can.
So this is,
this is a very significant social challenge created by new technology.
It's,
it's this sort of new digital divide.
A wage inequality is growing within occupations.
Uh,
also because access to,
uh,
to,
to the new technology is limited by people,
by people skills.
You know,
whether they can get the job to,
to learn on the job.
Jobs are shifting more to it using occupations.
Wages are growing faster for it users.
The limited access means that some people are going to benefit and some people
are going to be left behind and there's rising inequality.
So what does that say about policy?
I'll just talk a few minutes more and wrap this up.
Um,
how can we address the,
this digital divide problem with policy?
Some ideas and I'll just talk very briefly.
Why don't you know.
So here's this problem.
How do we deal with skills that are learned on the job?
Well,
one thing is work study programs.
You're seeing manufacturers,
for instance,
working with local community colleges to set up programs where people learn some
skills in the classroom and some skills on the job.
Some companies are experimenting,
experimenting with apprenticeship type programs.
Uh,
we're seeing a number of industries,
uh,
and it's certainly true in tech,
but you know,
a number of more traditional industries,
uh,
working with ways of certifying skills so that people who do learn on the job
can get the certification so that labor markets can recognize those skills and
reward them for what they've learned to get the incentives right.
Uh,
another thing is standardization.
When s when,
uh,
the new technology is highly fragmented across multiple standards,
it becomes difficult to teach in a classroom to certify a,
so one thing that is helpful as open standards.
Another thing is knowledge sharing of various sorts.
In the book,
I talk about how historically,
uh,
government procurement was often played a key role in this.
And so you people talk about the role of government in,
for instance,
fostering the development of semiconductors or the computer or the Internet and
an important way government played.
One way government played an important role was in establishing norms of
knowledge sharing and,
and unopened standards so that,
uh,
there could be develop a cadre of skilled technical people who shared common
knowledge and could then take what we're initially typically defense or,
or NASA type applications and bring them to civilian applications.
Civilian uses.
A third thing that is important is employee mobility.
Labor markets for new skills,
uh,
depend on having employees who can switch jobs,
possibly switch occupations easily.
We've unfortunately seen a decline in employee mobility,
a very substantial decline over the last 15 years or so.
Uh,
things that may be contributing to that are a agreements,
um,
occupational licensing,
uh,
expansions of trade secret law and,
and,
and even patents.
Um,
so tailoring those things so that they,
they provide the important benefits where those benefits are needed but did not
unnecessarily impede employee mobility,
I think are,
are important factors.
So,
to conclude,
what about the next 10 or 20 years?
And it was,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm now going beyond the book.
I,
I've been sort of riffing on the book,
starting with things that are in the book and drawing on some,
some more recent research,
but my guess is that we're going to mostly see continued job growth and the
impact.
In other words,
the impact of information technology has largely been positive unemployment in
the last 10 to 30 years.
And I think that's going to largely continue for the next 10 or 20 years.
Uh,
because whether,
you know,
the,
the economics say that,
what's driving that is that the nature of demand,
it's not the nature of technology.
In fact,
people say,
well,
okay,
Moore's law,
we're going to have technology moved faster.
Uh,
what that says,
for my understanding of the economics is,
well that just means,
uh,
employment growth,
employee employment will grow fast,
not that it will decline.
Uh,
we may sooner reached the point where things start to decline.
You know,
we,
we saw that the,
you know,
the,
the inverse you inverted u shape of textable or manufacturing employment
generally.
Um,
but I think the immediate impact of technology,
even accelerated technology,
uh,
will be two will be positive,
will not be negative in terms of him in terms of the number of jobs.
They're going to be.
Some important exceptions to that,
uh,
where the technology is 100% autonomous self driving vehicles for instance.
Um,
clearly the technology is going to be able to replace humans,
but that,
you know,
if you look at what's being developed in,
in my view,
at least in my understanding in it,
and I wish we had better data on this,
um,
the most of the applications of AI are going through things that enhance human
capabilities rather than replace them.
Um,
we're also going to see saturated demand.
So we see saturated demand in manufacturing industries.
And gradually as,
uh,
automation progresses,
we can expect more in,
in,
in other areas.
Uh,
but the,
the,
the real challenge,
which I think will,
will only intensify over the coming years is this digital divide.
We're going to see greater,
a greater contribution of,
uh,
technology to wage inequality.
And from the employer's point of view,
we're going to see,
uh,
Eh,
you know,
complete their co today complaints about a skills gap that people can hire,
uh,
employees with the right skills.
I think that will probably worse than to,
unless we can somehow reverse the,
some of the policy directions that we,
we've seen so far.
So to sum up,
uh,
the,
the problem we face today in my view is scarce skills,
not scarce jobs.
Um,
thank you.
That's a good question.
Um,
you know,
I think undoubtedly geographic inequality is a major part of the inequality we
see today.
That said,
I think you want to be a bit careful.
Um,
part of the reason that's true is because things aren't working well.
Labor markets aren't working well,
people aren't willing to relocate,
uh,
as much as economists thing.
Um,
or,
or in other,
or at least their,
their preferences,
preferences or not to relocate.
But it's,
it's also important not to,
um,
I think it's easy to be sort of coastal league,
a little nearsighted.
Um,
that the,
the skills to develop the very latest technology and really work at the cutting
edge are one thing.
And those are going to be concentrated in clusters.
But if we talk,
see,
let's talk about graphic designers graphic,
you know,
they're graphic designers in every city in the,
in the nation.
Now it turns out that the hot markets for graphic designer in New York and San
Francisco,
you areas where there's a lot of advertising.
You,
you don't,
I mean there's some geographic concentration there,
but there's also a lot of graphic tee.
I mean there were a lot of graphic designers throughout the country,
the people designing Webs,
web websites all over the country.
Um,
it may well be true that if I'm an Iowa,
I may have a harder time getting access to a training unless I leave.
Uh,
I may have a harder time getting learning on the job skills.
I think that that may be that that's one of the critical things.
So another,
this is what I'm,
I was trying to say is that because it,
it depends on learning on the job.
You have to be where the key jobs are with it.
With the advanced jobs are,
if,
if we can get to the point where we can learn more in school,
learn more in text books,
learn more online into,
you know,
where the knowledge becomes more standardized,
then it becomes that much more easier for somebody.
And I want to acquire the skills without having to relocate.
There are certainly some nice examples of companies doing things that are
getting people certain skills.
So some of these examples where companies have worked with a local community
colleges for instance,
or Siemens has,
is playing around with an interesting program where they,
it's kind of an apprenticeship program where,
uh,
you know,
skills skills are developed,
are getting developed.
I think on a larger scale you can look at some industries where industry models
are working well.
So,
particularly in health care,
uh,
you're seeing,
however screwed up the US healthcare system is,
uh,
there are some things that,
some business models that are very encouraging in the book.
I write about ambulatory care centers,
these outpatient clinics for that,
a very specialized,
um,
and they,
they've been a big growth area.
Uh,
they,
they are able to deliver their though these specialized services at lower costs
and greater quality,
greater performance.
Um,
but it turns out that they were a great way for middle-skill healthcare workers
to acquire skills learned on the job because their specialization be so when a
nurse goes in and is seeing knee patients day after day after day after day,
rather than working in a hospital where they're seeing every sort of different
patient,
they're able to quickly learn,
uh,
you know,
what matters,
what's,
what problems are significant and need to come to the attention of the
physicians,
the surgeons,
uh,
which problems are not important or it can be handled with aspirin and bed rest
or you know,
whatever.
The entire healthcare system is being turned upside down in this way.
Where before it was sort of the,
the doctors on top giving orders to everyone and now it's sort of a triage
system.
You start with the lower level personnel who are going to screen you and because
they have this knowledge now,
uh,
are playing a much more valuable at all.
And so what we're seeing is employment going up for those jobs.
We're seeing wages going up for those jobs and that's actually working rather
well.
The demand for people with with skills is going up.
Yes.
Um,
I think basically this,
this is in a sense the challenge that,
that I would put it in sort of in the reverse,
that if we can develop
on a social scale,
if we can develop them,
the institutions to two d to bring people up to speed on the new skills,
we're going to be much better off in terms both in terms of,
uh,
delivering,
things that might otherwise require a turn towards automation.
But we're going,
I think the technology can basically take two courses.
We can focus on technology that enhances human capabilities or in technology
that replaces it.
If we do a good job at,
uh,
at,
at developing skills,
we're going to make it much more economical to focus on the enhancement.
Um,
now that's if we look 30,
50,
60 years out,
I don't know,
uh,
we're,
we're gonna we are gonna going to face a significant,
uh,
end of work type problem.
We are going to face a situation where the technology may be very capable of
replacing lots of jobs.
Uh,
but we're going to be much better prepared for that.
Number one,
if we can delay that point,
which will happen,
I think if we are developing skills better.
And number two,
as we do this,
as we,
as we work more gradually from an a mode where most of the technology is going
to enhance rather than replace,
uh,
we,
we can work more gradually and it gives us the time to develop the social
institutions to deal with the problems that are going to resolve them and that
sort of thing.
So the people,
I don't think that tends to be so much technologically determined.
So the factory worker for instance,
that most people would say,
well,
factory work is one of those examples.
You come in and,
and it's a fixed job and you know,
you're there and that's it.
And you're being hired as an unskilled worker off the street.
Uh,
you look at what actually happened in the 19th century factories and there's
still a lot of that happening today in today's factories.
Um,
number,
when people came in,
they did switch from job to job.
Uh,
so the,
the,
the people who made it into weaving often started at a,
at a lesser skilled job and graduated into,
into weaving where they could make bigger bucks or even into a supervisory type
roles.
So when you have,
you know,
a very mature industry,
an older workforce where people have been doing this stuff for a long time,
they're gone.
There aren't going to be opportunities for much flexibility and,
and,
and you know,
that,
that may limit things.
But when we're talking about new technologies,
even in older industries,
um,
it seems to me there's,
there,
there has to be room for a lot of different organizational approaches.
Right?
So we,
we've experimented in the past,
uh,
you know,
with programs particularly for trade related to displacement of jobs.
These tough tended to be small term,
small scale programs.
Um,
it certainly makes sense that when people have,
are being technologically displaced that we provide a combination of retraining
and some sort of income support.
On the other hand,
I think we need to be careful that we don't make the income support by itself,
uh,
you know,
a permanent feature or that that provides disincentives for people to move on
and acquire the new skills.
Uh,
and that reflects my,
at least my view that people are going to be better off if they are gainfully
employed,
if they have valuable skills.
Um,
not only from an economic point of view,
which I think will be a more secure economically,
it will be more secure politically.
Um,
but also I think in terms of people's well wellbeing,
I think for an awful lot of people having a gainful unemployment where they're
doing something they feel is valuable,
is important for their personal wellbeing.
Yet or better yet combined.
I mean,
I'm a big believer in some of these work study programs because it combines the
best of both that that you have people who are motivated,
they can see the practical relevance and at the same time they can get sort of
the formal background.
So they have a deeper understanding than they might get.
Just just learning on the job.
I focus on that because that's the most prevalent form of work relationship.
Um,
so all of these things have their own advantages and disadvantages regarding
skills development.
So it,
and I,
this is a much longer discussion I think.
But,
uh,
so one of the problems is when we have,
when labor markets aren't functioning all that well,
uh,
the incentives for the employers or,
and the incentives for the employees aren't really what they need to be.
And so you have sort of these catch 22 situations where an employer is trying to
find people who have the skills but yet isn't willing to invest as much as they
need to in training people.
And at the same time you have employees who are looking for jobs and looking at
what skills they might want to acquire themselves.
They don't have the best incentives.
If we,
if we replace the relationship with a Gig economy type relationship,
it's not clear to me that that's going to necessarily improve things in might
melt well,
make things worse.
But I have to say it depends.
Um,
so let,
let,
let me leave it at that.
I want to hire a graphic designer to do my website and we're going to have this
kind of website using this type of technology,
blah,
blah.
I go out and I asked for resumes and so I'm looking,
I get experienced people have five years experience,
two years experience,
10 years experience.
Is that experience the right kind of experience that I need?
Uh,
it has to be the right kind of experience,
not only for the particular tools that I'm using,
but the kind of organization.
Uh,
so we have websites that are,
you know,
large websites that require these complex organizational links with databases
and people in different departments and all sorts of specialties.
And working in that environment is itself a,
a learn skill.
Um,
so it,
it becomes very hard for me to know that if I'm looking at you as a job
candidate,
do you really have those skills or not?
I can find out who you work for and how long you worked.
And I can maybe understand what skills you tell me you've got.
But it's,
it's,
it's very hard for me to make a judgment as opposed to a situation where
somebody is a certified developer on such and such tool.
Uh,
you know,
that that tells me,
uh,
you know,
they,
they've got the skill,
I need a,
it's a standardized skill.
I'm going to,
I can hire that person when you,
now the problem is when you get that situation where employers have a hard time
judging,
um,
they may not be willing to pay as much as,
as they should do to reward the skills.
Uh,
they,
um,
they may not be or eh,
as eager to hire,
uh,
as they should.
Uh,
so you know,
the,
the labor market signals of,
of,
um,
you know,
what your value is worth it.
Are,
you know,
once those are off,
then both your,
your incentives to acquire a skill are diminished because you acquire the skill
and you can't prove it right.
And the employers,
you know,
willingness to pay you for that skill is off,
uh,
because they have a hard time telling.
And,
and the,
the,
those,
those things are all exacerbated if the skills are constantly changing.
If the standards are constantly changing or a fragmented,
uh,
I'm probably the wrong person that has,
you may have noticed this is not on the best seller list.
Um,
I know,
I know where I have gotten the greatest bang in,
in,
in publication and that is,
I guess this is the sort of thing that the public grasps on and it's still
relatively sophisticated,
but it's my ATM example.
So I don't know,
I mean,
there's been just a number,
I'm ignorant of how this,
you know,
this process works of,
of changing public opinion.
But what I noticed is that there are certain like means or examples or things
that just sort of take on a life of their own.
And this is one of them.
Um,
everybody thought,
including Obama to made the comments that,
you know,
the ATM destroyed the bank teller and this just sort of challenges that wisdom
and people can sort of
grasp that at,
at a certain level without necessarily understanding why entirely.
But it,
it,
it gives people some understanding that it's not simply a matter of automate,
just because automation can take over certain skills doesn't mean it takes over
jobs.
So that's a real serious problem.
And,
and,
and I mean,
the,
the short answer is no,
but I,
I,
it's,
uh,
there's a,
a connection to this whole argument,
which is,
you know,
I,
I'm a typesetter for 25 years and the newspaper eliminates type setting.
Uh,
do I go learn a new skill or what do I do or do I drop out?
So I've got to either make an investment in a new skill or I can take a much
lower paying job,
um,
or I can drop out of the workforce.
And,
you know,
unfortunately,
I think we're seeing a certain amount of the drop out of the workforce,
particularly for people,
older people,
older workers.
Uh,
and,
and it,
it makes sense that they,
it just isn't necessarily when it's difficult to acquire the skills and may
require a significant investment and even then,
maybe may has have uncertain benefits because things aren't working as they
should entirely.
Uh,
unfortunately the decision than many people rationally make maybe to drop out of
the labor force.
So it's really part of the same.
The answer is the same as,
you know,
it's just a different manifestation at the same problem.
So complexities the heart has at the heart of the problem and the learning by
doing it,
it's only because
technologies are complex that you know,
that there's so many things that have to be learned,
that many of them are in the,
you know,
the less frequent reaches that occur less,
less often and so aren't standardized and,
and,
uh,
so that they can be presented in,
in a,
in a textbook way.
And in that that was actually actually true of things like textile technology
just as much as it is,
I think today or maybe even it's maybe even more so today.
But the complexity was in fact the big challenge then if you look at how and
what it took to transport those jobs overseas.
So,
uh,
by 1910 when I showed that that weaving room,
in fall river,
uh,
the most advanced technical equipment was actually installed all over the world
in Japan,
in China,
in Russia,
and India.
Uh,
they had the same equipment and it's some cases they even imported,
particularly British textile managers to run some of some of these mills.
Uh,
but the mills,
uh,
in those countries at that time were dramatically less productive.
I like s one six that in other words,
the workers were paid much,
much less,
but they were also much,
much less productive.
So it was a difficult process to learn those skills.
Uh,
gradually over time they figured out the way.
And,
and to some extent,
both in Japan and in China,
they followed the model of the sort of the Lowell mills.
Uh,
initially having boarding houses where they brought in young women to work,
you know,
to,
to work on the loons.
And I mean,
so you,
you still in China have these,
these um,
um,
you know,
dormitory type factories,
which are essentially a very similar model.
So they,
it,
it took time.
But I mean,
I,
I wouldn't,
um,
there,
yes,
there are certain skills that are very simple and can be learned and things
like,
I think particularly now electronic assembly maybe,
maybe that's,
that's more so the case,
but there,
there are even there no more sophisticated skills that,
that have been learned.
And you can see it takes time to set up the institutions to set up the,
the,
the labor markets to get things working so that,
uh,
things like technical skills can be learned and people can be compensated.
So the challenge we face today,
I think it probably is true that many of these technologies,
they're much more obscure.
Uh,
I,
I can explain what the complexity and textiles is.
It,
you know,
it's,
it's something will happen,
but it will happen very rarely.
And so somebody needs a lot of experience too to understand when it's going to
happen and what it looks like and how to avoid it.
Uh,
with some of these machine learning systems,
uh,
you know,
the probabilities of some of the events happening are so remote that there isn't
a,
it's not only a skill problem,
it's also a problem of,
um,
I mean I think,
I think there's a,
an essential quality problem in managing the technology that that's an interest.
So,
you know,
think about self driving cars.
We're seeing,
you know,
sort of these black swan events that we have to worry about.
So Tesla has this car and there's,
it thinks that a truck crossing the road is an overhead sign.
You know,
it's a weird event that happens very rarely,
neither the of the technology nor the human driver knows to be aware of that.
They don't have that skill.
Right.
Um,
so we,
we,
we have to,
I think with his technology generally,
we have to understand how we're going to manage these sort of a long tail,
uh,
events,
that are both things that make skills difficult to acquire.
And also make it difficult to maintain quality of the products.
I buy this,
you're talking where somebody comes on for a limited period of time and they see
how they do.
Yeah.
It's a way in that those things aren't necessary.
I mean,
it's,
some of those things were used in the past as well.
Um,
it's a way of,
of gaging and employees,
uh,
abilities when you,
when the labor market signals aren't so clear.
Um,
but it's also,
it's also difficult to,
to,
for to,
it's difficult and expensive for it to work well.
Um,
so it's very much the same sort of statistical problem we were just talking
about that you don't necessarily see how well an employee does until they've
really worked a long time because the random,
you know,
there's a Pr,
a probabilistic element that makes the signal very noisy.
Um,
so it's a way of dealing with the problem,
but it's,
it's not a solution.
It's a way of ameliorating the problem.
In some cases it can,
but it comes with costs.
Well,
thank you for having me.